And advance pay for performance system rewards providers who are able to
provide higher quality care, at a lower cost. There's evidence that
these programs can work. Here are the results of the physician group practice or
PGP demo. A well known medicare pilot, conducted in ten medical practices.
All of the groups achieved improvements in 25 of 27 quality metrics, for
the key diseases shown here. And you, you see the percentage of improvement,
as well. Four practices earned a bonus, for outstanding performance.
Marshfield Clinic earned half of the total bonus. And in explaining how
they did it, their CEO cited a well developed electronic health record. And
went on to describe how it reduced unnecessary duplication of services by making
information available, to all providers caring for each patient.